it looks like there's real fraud there
it looks like there's some real
Shenanigans there at the very least
there was voting machines that weren't
working properly and it seems very
suspicious that a lot of them were in
Republican areas
there's a lot of shenanigans there's a
and I think there's coordinated efforts
to make sure that certain people get
elected I don't know how far they go but
I know it's not zero he's right it is
not zero even Bill Barr said I wasn't
zero and that's the big question 69
percent of Republicans think there was
widespread fraud and Biden did not win
so uh there was a tweet it was Robbie
Starbuck put out a poll saying do you
think we're in a civil war and of course
you all know how I voted in that poll
but uh the overall majority of people
said yes there were four choices one was
nowhere not and then one was not yet but
soon and that was the second most voted
position